two liquids either one by itself
but mix them
i'd like to say never been to a police
station where someone picked up an ied
and brought it into the police station
but unfortunately i have so that's
pretty realistic my name is lloyd davis
i'm a former british army ammunition
technical officer
during my time in military i specialize
in counter-terrorism hostage rescue bomb
disposal
or improvised explosive device disposal
i'm now a defense consultant
and i also work with industry to develop
counter eod capabilities
and today i'll be reviewing some
hollywood bomb disposal
shot i got on series plane felt
something depressed on my right foot
pretty sure the landline his reaction in
this particular case is
very realistic of the kind of guy you
know these are um
these are seals they are incredibly
professional incredibly stoic
nobody move we're in a minefield
what we saw there that that pile of
rocks is uh it's fairly realistic
particular in afghanistan where
pressure plate ied is replaced quite a
lot so that's a little pressure plate
buried in the ground
attached to explosives to target
personnel or vehicles
they would often be marked to either
warn the local population and they would
mark them with piles of stones rags
flags that kind of thing
the issue i have is that's not how
landmines work there is absolutely no
benefit
in designing a landmine that works on
arming under pressure
and then firing on pressure release you
know what you're trying to do is
is initiate the explosion when that
target is in the exact
place you want it to be and in this case
the exact place you want that target to
be when the the mind functions is
directly on top of it
and it's a huge misnomer that there's
this opportunity to
stand on a landmine stay perfectly still
and then work your way out of that
situation
if you stand on it that's that's it it's
going to function were he in this
situation
with his foot over a pressure plate i
think maybe they are in
you know going about this the right way
they're probably limited very much to
what their options are
so what it looks like they're trying to
do is they've created two fixed points
in the ground they're going to tie a
string between them to keep the tension
down over that
pressure plate how they act how they
respond and stuff yeah i can believe
that
um but unfortunately from the explosive
point of view uh that's a zero
okay right now he's just diving straight
in there which is uh
it's probably not the best approach yeah
yeah of course you'd stroke it that's
fine
you know when the british army were
working in iraq towards the back end the
the bomb suit itself
was becoming tailored we would only use
the top half of the bomb suit
uh mainly because of the heat and
exhaustion you're gonna be doing this
for about 45 minutes to an hour
uh in ridiculous heat so the the bombs
is realistic that's fine
approaching without using your robot
first probably less so really you want
to do minimal interaction with the bomb
so very rarely would you just start
picking up things moving stuff around
he's identified the the detonating chord
that's going into the main chart itself
it's an artillery shell
and he's trying to separate that
detonator before breaking down the
explosive train so
it's not complete rendering it's safe
but uh it's going to take that small pop
which is still pretty dangerous but it's
not going to bring down the entire
neighborhood so fairly reasonable sort
of rsp
or render safe procedures so far
so he's just pulling that detonator or
blasting cap
out of the the fuse well absolutely no
looking around to see what else it's
connected to or what that
why i might be doing all right we're
done
good to go there are lots of guys
watching
recording and filming what he's doing
that's absolutely realistic one place is
most likely going to be watching so
they understand what we do
yeah we don't do that either we don't we
don't pull up wires to see where they go
so this is actually really really common
in uh in afghanistan and
particularly in iraq they do what we
call daisy chains so they link multiple
main charges usually along the side of
the road and what he's doing there is
he's pulling on the
electric wires that are connected to the
blasting cap previously
he just removed by hand quite easily now
those shelves are
somewhere in the region 25 kilos upwards
um
he's now just just dragging around
pulling out the dirt
but uh not something you want to do
we're gonna see him run straight to what
we call the firing point which is the
the two bare wires on the wall
if this is a what we call proxy bombs
they'll probably have a handler they'll
probably have someone watching
and there'll be two triggers to this
particular bomb they'll be the
uh the intended trigger so a push button
or something on the desk itself
something that they're carrying or maybe
distracting to
there are most likely particularly
around
the mobile phone threat was pretty high
so there'd be probably a
whole an rc or remote control trigger
attached to the vest as well but
precisely this situation
and we'd call that a chicken switch so
if the the bomber decided to chicken out
uh his handler could detonate him at a
moment's notice
oh man the priority is separating the
bomb from the person not necessarily
dealing with the bombs so
he'd be gone as soon as that's been
dropped off i can't get it off i'm sorry
okay
you understand i'm sorry i'm sorry get
down as near the operator you feel
particularly responsible
and there is very little he can do
there's no point in
wasting his own life
it's one of the more realistic um
hollywood explosions that
i say we've seen yeah there was a
sizable amount of uh
plastic explosive all over that guy if
you can double the distance between
you and the device um you actually
expose yourself to about a quarter of
the
uh the shock wave and blast wave you
experience
so any any foot he could have got
further away from that
would have uh would have helped the
first scene we saw
for absolute realism i'd give it about a
two or three out of ten
but this scene's probably a sevens
[Music]
i remember watching this in the cinema
and i happen to be there with
some colleagues at the time one of whom
was actually tasked
with being part of the team that would
render safe improvised
nuclear devices and some of the others
were special forces operators and
we all had a lot to say about this clip
the bomb itself is quite reminiscent of
the
bombing goldfinger there's a really
weird mix of
mechanical devices clicking around and
going on complicated electronics you're
particularly never going to get two
timers
one mechanical one digital counting down
at the same time join this screw
counterclockwise got it when the time
comes
cut the green wire do not cut it yet
okay we copy
another thing is this this innate
knowledge of the
the heroes to have a almost
textbook-like
understanding of the makeup of these
devices and be able to say oh it's uh
this switch from this area we're gonna
do this
that doesn't happen it's bespoke there
are certain things you know
the generic makeup of how these things
operate you can't get around physics
um but you know knowing exactly what
color wire and things to do is just not
believable
and i'm cutting that wire he's built in
the software to just slowly open up and
expose the core of this device
there's absolutely no reason why the bom
designer would design that feature into
this bomb
even if you've managed to render safety
the trigger mechanism all of this
all right there's still a huge amount of
work to do to start taking that apart
and get rid of the uh
the actual radioactive element of this
you've got multiple devices
all having to be cut exactly the same
time and they're all synchronized
that just uh that doesn't work we've
tried
cutting wires uh at simultaneous times
with multiple people across different
parts of the room
um or even on the same device if
everything's linked
you know if you've tried it in training
um there is just no way you're gonna be
fast enough to beat switches in an
electrical system by cutting
things simultaneously i'll give it a two
out of ten just because the
the physics we found this in a
playground this stuff is cutting edge
it's a binary liquid a what yeah it's
that's pretty common for
any of the tech to geek out and get
excited about the
devices found or what he's been doing
i'd like to say
i've never been to a police station
where someone thought they picked up an
ied and brought it into the police
station
but unfortunately i have so that's
pretty realistic
two liquids either one by itself
but mix them
so yeah binary explosives exist well
essentially any simple explosive mixture
is two
separate um chemicals that just mix
together in this case
he's mixing uh what would be a fuel and
then oxidizer to make an incredibly
sensitive explosive
very high tech bomb very impressive
explosive technology
and you're definitely not going to get
that kind of explosion out of that small
amount
this guy being a you know a serial bomb
maker and they have existed in the past
you know they probably will exist again
in a sort of large bombing campaign like
that uh even afghanistan were actually
there
the bomb maker will develop the
signature they will develop
multiple bombs and a lot of what we did
in particular afghanistan when we were
serving there
was try and gather evidence be it
forensics or
just bond style the technology exists so
i'd give it a 6 out of 10.
i can't do it i can't do it man his legs
he's been on there for like 18
20 hours he can't even walk let alone
hop off the can okay
so that's actually a really really good
point his legs are probably numb he's
fatigued
he's dehydrated he's scared he's
unlikely to be jumping up and running
around anywhere anytime soon
he might however just faintly fall off
the toilet so
i'd probably be physically restraining
him and holding him in place at this
point in time
now what he's doing sergeant is spraying
this thing with liquid nitrogen
that should give you a good second or
two before detonation covering something
in liquid nitrogen to freeze
uh the switch in place in theory it's a
mechanical attack you're attacking the
physical mechanisms of that switch and
holding it in place it's going to do
nothing for the electrics
it's not a good idea it would not be
something we do against
an improvised explosive device like this
uh you have no idea
what that extreme cold temperature is
going to do how the components are going
to react to that
they're pouring it in the wrong place
the switch is going to be right
underneath him
okay get him up get him out let's go
first of all there's only gonna be one
person dealing with this
yep bond blankets containment of
explosions all things we try and do
i have one sturdy toilet you know the
whole side of the house goes out for
that porcelain toilet stays intact um
he's probably better off just sitting on
top of that rather than jumping in the
tub
you know at the very minimum you'd
expect his eardrums for rupture
all the soft tissues in his body
particularly as long as his bowel are
very susceptible to blast wave shock
wave
essentially you get a really bad bruise
all over those linings there's lots of
blood
and you can suffer for what we call dry
land drowning which is where all the the
blood vessels in the lining of your lung
rupture and your lungs are filled with
blood as engineering with time
or you get blast bowel which is slightly
less severe
and essentially the same thing your
bowel starts filling with blood and you
bleed
internally in training i've dealt with a
toilet bomb before the
probably weirdest place i found one um
was in a bathroom originally by the time
i got to it the
uh the landlord had thrown out the
window and collected by the police and
driven back to a police station i'd give
it one out of ten
i'm going to cut the blue wire
my lads will wait if i go in the wrong
way
they'll know what to do so there's so
much about this that i really like so
i think his attitude and demeanor doing
what he's doing is is perfect the
communication back and forth so that
that reach back as we call it to
someone who's not under that pressure
someone who's got the scientific support
and support of other people
around them can think maybe slightly
clearer or cooler than you are
is very realistic
it's never going to be a simple red or
blue choice
a bomb is going to contain at least
seven components from a power source
to your main explosives your initiator
switches it's never as simple
unfortunately as red or blue
and if it is um you do a little bit more
investigating where you decide to cut
the wire
um and now there's one guiding principle
when we're working this kind of
job um and if you say you're going to do
something you do it
for exactly that reason if you can
explain it to your mother as to why
you're taking the action you shouldn't
be doing it
so you are 100 sure when you do anything
as near the operator
no way that you swap between decisions
or do something that you
or not do something that you said you're
going to do so the vast majority of ieds
that we've experienced
in afghanistan particularly are very
very simple they're very simple very
simple electronics
very simple circuits if you if you were
to cut any of the wires
you've probably broken the bomb enough
to make it somewhat safer
without having done a full investigation
of what you're dealing with um you
generally don't
start cutting wires and hoping your
guests that's very
very surefire way to make sure that you
uh you don't survive very long doing
this job
he would never change his mind at that
last moment so unfortunately i can't
give it a 10 out of 10 but uh
i'm going to go with a pretty high nine
on this one
i've laid out what you'll need okay so
you've got the uh
expo and political officer from so15
counterterrorism police
um they're a unit they exist they're
very good
um they are all ex-british army bombers
operators who transferred over to work
for the police and with the police and
he's going to let the the hostage
defuse his own bomb which is probably
his first mistake
he'd easily put that small tool bag on
the robot to send that down
to the hostage i'm not going to manage
the one hand we'll start by freeing your
left hand
he's holding down what they call dms
it's not an abbreviation we use
in this case it stands for dead man
switch and whilst that button may be
very light to push you press a button
for an hour
and you're gonna feel some extreme pain
in your hands so he has taped his thumb
down onto it already which is something
we would do
quite lucky actually that that one's
pretty poorly designed all the circuits
exposed that's a pretty generous bomb
maker not to kind of just put a cover
over all of that that decision between
is this a
suicide bomber is this the hostage maybe
if you're entirely unsure and you're
suspecting more on the suicide bomber
lines then yeah maybe send a robot with
some tools down and try and get them to
start doing something to help out
in this case it would probably be much
more exposing the device
showing it to the the robot showing you
the components if there's other switches
i would say
mobile phones radios that kind of stuff
on there you wouldn't necessarily start
getting the
hostage to start taking the device apart
as you're about to see them
maintain pressure on the dms trigger
that particular action so far is what we
call mechanical blocking
um so you're basically doing a very
risky
um physical procedure not interacting
with anything electrically
um all he's doing is replacing his thumb
with something to hold that button down
in place before we leave
what we call the icp the instant control
point and make that manual approach or
in this case start doing any manual
actions
um we have a 100 plan of what we're
going to do
yeah no one's letting go of that twitch
no one is confident enough that they're
going to lift their thumb off that
without
uh without any audio operator making
them move it there's a whole load of
other things you'd get to before you
went anywhere near that and the last
thing i do
is trust the tape that's been on his
hand that's covered in mud blood and
sweat
okay so this is where this scene goes
even more wrong for me you know without
any diagnostics or understanding what
you're doing
trying to just jab electric wires into a
circuit board is a really
bad thing to do with the box this whole
clock speeding up and things so
it doesn't happen um you might do
something and
the best you can hope for is nothing
happening so winced at this the first
time i watched it i had a lot of people
texting me asking me how real it was
so i'm going to give it two out of ten
stanley goodspeed
agent trainee marvin wood initiated exam
of wooden crate
hazmat suits everything we use them in
certain situations
hazmat suits are designed specifically
for these chemical agents
[Music]
that's kudos to the bomb maker right
there i mean to make a creepy baby doll
that sprays sarin gas this is not a
learning opportunity
all your training is done in a training
environment where there's no danger
explosive and poison gas to blow the
whole chamber and kill everybody in the
building
it doesn't make sense it's got two main
charges or two payloads
you've got the sarin gas that's a
a chemical warfare agent it's a
neurotoxin
and what that does is it paralyzes the
muscles by blocking what's called ach
and that's the chemical sort of
messaging system between nerves
totally deadly on its own there is
absolutely no need
to put enough c4 in there to blow up the
room
somewhat de facto antidote to nerve
agent
um you don't have to inject it directly
into your heart you generally go for a
uh a large fleshy muscle area like your
thigh or buttocks
great now soaking uh an electrically
initiated ied with water
generally a really bad idea you know i
have no idea what short circuit that's
going to create or what damage that's
going to do
really elegant string of pearls
configuration unfortunately incredibly
unstable
yeah so an incredibly unstable elegant
string of pearls
um is a terrible weapon design
so that that sits within a rocket it's
going to get launched by a booster motor
and it's going to fly over the speed of
sound or however fast this thing is
going to go
unfortunately that's going to be subject
to a lot of physics and one of those
those
uh forces it's going to be subject to is
setback force
where essentially the the acceleration
of the rocket
increases the g-force of those those
pearls
and they're going to get compressed
against each other really really hard so
pretty much instantly as soon as that
thing launches those are all going to
crack and you just can get
melted bx spraying out this thing as
it's flying along
the cholinesterase inhibitor stops the
brain from sending nerve messages down
the spinal cord within 30 seconds
but that's after your skin melts off
that's fairly accurate
exactly how you feel it um what you
wouldn't get is the huge blistering and
skin melting that you saw earlier in the
movie
fantastic movie unfortunately not very
realistic at all um
not from an eod or weapons design point
of view
this drive sounds funny except for
slowing it down yeah i could have told
you that what are we gonna do
it would take probably more effort than
it's worth to set that up as far as a uh
as far as programming goes if she's been
sat there for hours typing that code out
i'd probably get the guy in the bomb
suit start typing the code for her give
her a bit of a rest let her relax
hi who the hell are you i love
james dove particularly in a hostile
situation like this is
possible and one of the key things we
try and do is is build rapport
you've got to try and keep them as calm
as you can yeah you would strip down
you wouldn't or remove the barriers as
far as helmets and body armor and the
likes to get on with this
you like red wine or white one
the truth is we we don't get anything um
if we don't know we don't do it so i'd
probably go
for a two out of ten for this one i
don't know maybe i'm wrong
you guys are the experts maybe you don't
need me this is um
so semtex am i right plastique
okay so he's the the disgruntled um
unappreciated specialist so far he's
identified some kind of plastic
explosive his semtex
i'm not convinced at this moment in time
but you know have i seen
stuff laid out on a a police table or in
a police lockup
probably shouldn't be there probably you
should have been dealt with i absolutely
have
what else do we have here oh this is a
a plunger detonator am i right and
that's a little mini receiver
he's talking absolute rubbish at this
point um
he's waffling about uh plunger
detonators and whatever else yeah
utter nonsense so for the technical
accuracy
um that's that basically a zero